tras semanas de negociación llega a un
acuerdo provisional alcanzado por el
presidente biden y el líder republicano
del Congreso Kevin mccarthy para
aumentar el techo de la deuda de Estados
Unidos de 31,4 billones de dólares el
documento evitaría efectos desastrosos
en la economía mundial teniendo en mente
las exigencias de demócratas y
republicanos el proyecto de ley deberá
obtener la aprobación del Congreso la
próxima semana antes de la fecha límite
del 5 de junio cuando se supone que se
agota el dinero del tesoro
Creo que este es un acuerdo en principio
digno del pueblo estadounidense contiene
reducciones históricas del gasto
reformas importantes que sacarán a la
gente de la pobreza y la incorporarán al
mercado laboral controlarán las
extralimitaciones del gobierno no hay
nuevos impuestos en ni nuevos programas
gubernamentales y hay mucho más en el
proyecto de ley Joe biden acudió a
Twitter destacando que el acuerdo era un
importante avance que protegería a los
trabajadores de una recesión económica
que podría ser perder millones de
puestos de trabajo también advirtió que
el un compromiso y que ambos bandos No
conseguían todo lo que querían aunque
los detalles del acuerdo aún no se han
hecho públicos los medios de
comunicación estadounidenses informan
que el acuerdo elevaría el techo de la
deuda durante dos años hasta después de
las elecciones presidenciales también
limitaría el gasto protegería el
presupuesto de defensa y endurecería
algunos requisitos para acceder a las
ayudas públicas el proyecto de ley se
votará el miércoles en la cámara de
representantes liderada por republicanos
que podría enviarlo después al senado
controlado por los demócratas pero en
los últimos días legisladores de ambos
partidos han expresado su temor a estar
cediendo demasiado al otro bando